Katie is with us in Boise Idaho hi Katie
how are you hi Dave thank you so much
for taking my call
sure what's up so my husband and I are
big fans and we just wanted to thank you
for all that you do so we are in our 30s
with two young kids and we are debt-free
except that we owe on our home still but
we also owe on two out of our three
rental properties so while it's really
cool to say we're debt-free essentially
we still have over half a million
dollars index all right I got you
so how much deep how much do you owe on
your home how much do you owe on your
home on our residents its 266 that we
owe still okay and so about another 250
on the other two rentals then correct
okay all right and what are the what are
the three rentals together worth um
they're rentals together let's see it's
about 230 205 and 206 30 all together
for all three of them okay one is paid
off and the other two are not light
rentals and ideally we'd like to have
ten of them pay dogs
what's your household income 245 sorry
140,000 okay and what is your home worth
about 327 okay she got substantial
equity and every one of these properties
then is what you're telling me so what
is your question right I guess my
question is my husband died our though
divided on this um should we pay off our
current residents should we work on
paying off the two rentals should be
spelled out rental that is paid off you
know to put towards either our home or
the rentals what would you suggest we've
been playing a guessing game of what
would they say so we decided it was a
call and actually find out okay well at
the minimum of the three properties the
first one you pay off as your home okay
that's the minimum you do so we're going
to pay nothing extra on the rentals
everything extra on the home until the
homeless and that's a risk management
perspective meaning in a worst-case
scenario if I was going to lose
something I'd rather lose rentals than
lose my home and so I'd rather have it
paid off first and that's outside that
so I'm going to knock out the house
first then the next level you could go
to is to say well we could sell some
rentals maybe pick out my least favorite
one and use whatever equity comes from
that to pay on the house and accelerate
this process so of the three properties
which is your least favorite well the
one with our least favorite probably is
the one that's paid off
yeah and what's it worth and that one's
worth 200 okay just about pay your house
off wouldn't it right and that's what I
started battling with a couple weeks ago
in October we put about 15,000 towards
paying off our house because that's what
we decided we thought we should go under
right so then now I'm like well then we
have 200 sitting there that we could use
but that also makes a substantial income
every month and like I said ideally we'd
like to keep our rentals and you know
continue it's up to you yeah it doesn't
matter there's not a bad answer you know
that the minimum is the first thing you
do is continue to pack on your house the
next step would be sell one rental the
next step would be sell two rentals in
the next step would be sell three
rentals how far you how far do you want
to go in you know to be debt-free I'm
probably selling one of them at a
minimum if I'm in your shoes anyway
because you're swimming in a big
mortgage here it's going to take you a
while to get clear of this and I'm going
to accelerate the process to become debt
free which is going to put me back in
the by paying off the rentals and then
put me back in the business of buying
rentals for cash faster faster
by having knocked by having sacrificed
this one on the altar of debt freedom so
to speak so it's just kind of a math
thing for me you know I love rentals so
I'm not gonna be bad about it either way
but I'm proud of being debt-free more
and so if I woke up in your shoes I'm
probably selling that one the one
like least and throwing that at my house
be debt-free on the house within a year
then knock out the others rentals and
then start saving up and paying cash for
rentals and grow into your ten eight
four as your idea and your goal is I
think you're going to get there just a
matter how fast you get there this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind